and going back to Jim Morrison I'm not
sure how well you knew but I believe he
wanted to be a filmmaker very very badly
and sometimes I've read even more so
than actually being musician well he was
in film school I mean he you know my
experience I knew him very well we were
very good friends I he was surprised by
becoming a teenybopper Idol and a little
embarrassed about it and he was a
serious guy and what we had in co we
both had very conservative backgrounds
his father was an admiral my father was
an FBI agent and here we were in the
world of freaks in this Cultural
Revolution and
justice Sassa Columbia Pictures did not
fill me up the success that he had did
not fill him up
you